[Musica]
siamo io ciccio ciao ciccio però non ho
un importante tu il secondo da ciccio
g.co books lui e così è stato uno dei
giocatori più forti del mondo e di
rocketeer l'avete già visto sono uno dei
miei video un sacco di gente che gioca
rock e talenti ne abbiamo solo
fortissimo che palesi e forte poi c'è
anche l'altro ciccio vabbè comunque dai
vorrei vorrei trovare il account
primario di kukes il appunto che questo
per aggiungerlo agli amici per poter
registrare un video ci sono tanti fake
in come potete vedere ce ne sono
veramente un miliardo di fei 15 ho messo
un'ora per trovare quello giusto
credo sia questo non so se lo notate il
motivo però credo sia questo account
giusto aggiungiamo che uscirà nemici
facciamo un tributerà ecco run che è una
tua scelta quella poi magari ti facciano
perdere di radio1 si chiama almost lucky
quindi vuol dire che a fortune basta
possiamo vincere ciccio io lo so ci ho
provato ragazzo trovato
no no
si cerca di togliere la lila detto mamma
mia ragazzi si taglia la prima partita
questa era per era posizionato male
sulla sedia e roero seduto male sulla
sedia adesso li facciamo una serie ha
promesso chicho 6 carico
sono tornato carico io bravo è questo
che voglio super partaccia mai riuscirà
questa è la questa secondo me veramente
potevamo vincere la sola che siano stati
scarsi let's go brava brava attenzione
l'assegno io che sono forte allora
kucera tu devi andare dai film side e
dire ai have a a new make them that
chicche join us in the next world
championship and link per far bene che
vedo io questo gol me lo guarda me lo
sono guadagnato ho fatto tutto io e non
saprei come farlo meglio di così via
cold francesco berlino tibet is a good
sicilian gaia è il buffer a good pizza
ed a capofitto fino a poco fa questo ma
dove vanno questi non avranno questi ai
campionati del mondo vanno ma scherziamo
attenzione proprio lui mamma mia
promessa però non c'è mamma mia ragazzi
che sta vinciamo mai ciccio cattiveria
diventare ciccio mannaia proporre queste
cattive o prof
ha ragione la propria lasciate mai fatto
bene con il vantaggio ci pensa a lui
come la mette proprio lui lo re
bravissimo costa crociera corto protette
e successo a 2 bravo ciccio chi sei
veramente impegnato a questa partita dal
mio cosa farete fonti cioè non lo so
li ha dati per pietà provi mette voglia
ti prego togli la togli la toglie la
leaf niente ciccio niente faccio io
faccio io faccio io faccio guarda che
controllo guarda schifo
bravissimo bravo bravo
e gravissima gravissimo ma che sfiga
porca la o ciccio e ci ha creduto
cattivo così sempre qualora ora la
ciccia pro capite che sta guardando
l'azione dove vai ci sono e cattivo
capivo ciccio di spaccargli il computer
vedere tutta la famiglia no no non è
vero non è vero 168 li stai deviando con
lo sguardo ti guardano si non capisco
sporca di un bravissimo però andate
rincuorato aspettiamo con un 3 gol ma
chi diavolo affidiamo a noi l'abbiamo
chiusa
mamma mia ragazzi coastance che
rischiando qua bravissimo come la messa
bene per certi potete ancora di mezzo il
frigo ragazzi di supplico bravo bravo
bravo ciccio così tv o cattivo ma dosi
bravo ancora ancora toccato allora tutto
schifo porco vado indietro gr paro non è
vero l'ho tolto perché è andata fuori
non perché l'ho tolta io prova aperta ma
giochiamo quell'anno tolgono ero lì per
sfiga nuovo una ragazza dobbiamo vincere
ha giocato solo cussino ha segnato due
volte io per non si sa con 34 punti
tutto questo
bravo ufficio no no no no bravo sono
successe cose che non saprei spiegare
ciccio devi toglierla così bravo madonna
proprio lui la mette la mette lì la
mette lì a guardà l'assist assaggio di
assistiti da voci bravissimo c perché tu
bardelli marr marr.mi altra contattato
buono buono giorno prima quando primo
gol adesso ragazzi stiamo 30 secondi
così si mangia bene quello tentava ma
non fa
ragazzi io non so non so se siamo i
flipside o cosa ma so scrivere per noi
non lo farei
no volta come ho fatto a toglierla dai
ke skifo gioco truccato siamo forti
vinciamo noi contro i campioni eccelsi
lista mi questi erano scarsi
per questi ero toscana costa appena
preso il joystick proprio e ma noi
mettiamo anche i giocatori scarsi
noi giochiamo che google ip scarsi
perché tu a tutti va data una
possibilità a ragazzi questa nostra
partita
i clan props rocks e che sono i proxy
mia morire quindi ragazzi via veloci
veloci perfetto perfetto valore degli
dove di ghiaccio lo facciamo ingoiare
ciccio è stata questa partita è nostra e
di nessun altro
come capitano questi guardatevi asca
no dai cosa ciò va colta perché sono
forte e mi merito i tornei e sport
grazie a tutti perfetto vai o no me l'ha
tolta 8 mile amy ha demolito perché sua
madre sai dove lavora aiutasse dietro in
questo video
aspetta aspetta bravissimo cari studenti
quanti la office
esatto poi ci spingono perché tu non sei
cattivo aspettava controllo non la
controllo più perché lei questo torneo
mondiale book sir
ti prego in pakistan mi stanno
impegnando trovare sembrava non fosse
europea siamo noi capire il problema e
potrebbe dovere se gli altri due membri
del team però non è detto ma perché io
la febbre ragazzi mi giustifico con
questa io sono devi muovere cc ora io
sono emozionato
vai verso il pallone ti ci presenta gesù
ma non c è niente ragazzi e il primo
quello sì da perché sono scarsi l'ha
fatto come la pipì tolto non capisco è
affatto arrivarci
vai gravissimo o è la mette proprio lì
proprio lì dove loro non ci arrivano
bravo ciccio lo sono classi considerava
l'altro perché è distratto gli avversari
delle fratte veloce grazie scrive lo
cincia tripoli non capiscono niente
bravo bravo no chi è che me l'ha tolta
io e figurati parco sottile madonna
ci scusiamo ma il bello è che lui dice
non occupo della serie non lo parata
quindi entrerà per forza non vi dà per
scontato che noi non sappiamo un cap
cana giovani visto che ho visto al prato
del camp nou orologi ciò detto syfy
carte ragione bella tira ciccio da li
tira la forte mamma mia come lei
intimoriti io non li vedo più con il
joystick in mano spaventati come richard
benson che farò perdonare
mi sa che di notte ok cosa prova
no nessuno tira tirano solo gli
avversari qua
bravo a tu pensavi che fosse noi era
tutto calcolato
certo certo era un trick magico questo
tipo jack nobile bravissimo si va bene
anche io li segno così il sabato sera
dopo 8 pr dai ti prego ma almeno
l'inizio partire io no sì no no non devi
partire tum almeno andare il secondo
tranquillo lo re mi fa lo perdona di
nuovo si guarda come così bravi driver
tensione tra 3 e leila recuperano la
recuperata per la riprende put sir
volevo solo fatto bravo se l'ho visto
vado io tienila li tieni la ritira
michelina spacchiamo voci ciò così
modugno sono io valore
mamma mia mamma mia fratello batti il
cinque però non c'è la webcam opinione
però è bravissimo la faccia rumore io
noi avendo giocato nei flipside per
tanto tempo ci intendiamo
lo so che tu non puoi capire ciccio mai
ci intendiamo stato e la vincono proprio
con questo scambio di assist di cose la
vincono così gigi do you want a sign
com and ciccio merino
io spero che questo video sia piaciuto
ringrazio cook sir per averci per averci
i ragazzi se vi sia piaciuto ringrazio
veramente così vi lascio il canale di un
canale books è sì ma non lo uso non lo
uso vi lascio il guardate cucina i
mondiali frego non sa giocare noi ecco
guardate con fiere mondiali perché lui
gioca i mondiali
io gioco alle bocce coi vecchi euro
siamo vero quindi lo sapevo già che la
prego a tal proposito ci vediamo stasera
che fermando il vecchio di 80 anni vuole
giocare a bocce brin ha eroso i prossimi
siamo noi ragazzi scrivetemi bella
[Musica]